também já viu o ônibus da banda mole o
que eu quero que todos vocês imaginem
dentro de um ônibus em um bairro onde
grandão certo ônibus gigante todos
também pressiona os eua dirigindo esse
ano a gente está a 160 quilômetros por
hora
de repente esse ônibus bate no aparelho
a parede mais sólida que existe no
planeta
internamente todos nós morremos aqui nós
vemos uma pizza amassada
junto com o ônibus ok beleza isso a
discussão eu quero que fique muito claro
pra vocês percepção é uma ruptura é uma
quebra é absoluta é instantânea não é um
processo que acontece é uma quebra não
se enganem a interrupção é basicamente a
gente dentro do ônibus e ônibus andando
até a hora que ele pega e dá de cara
nessa parede que eu falei
ela vai acontecer e ela vai acontecer
com o negócio todos vocês dentro desse
contexto existe um trunfo turu que a
gente não vê esse é o tema do ted é por
isso que a gente está aqui dentro desse
futuro que a gente não vê eu quero falar
especificamente de negócios quando falo
de negócio não quero que vocês entendam
que estou falando só de empresas
estou falando de negócios e negócios
impacto na vida de todos vocês todos
vocês vão trabalhar em algum lugar ou
trabalharam em algum lugar o estudo em
algum lugar em certa monta isso vai
atacar também a vida de vocês têm um
isso muito muito claro
justamente por ser algo tão impactante e
tão intenso a corrupção é vista como um
risco por muita gente tem que dar um
exemplo
assista aqui em uberlândia certo na
terra do governo certamente vocês têm a
disney tem a fórmula indy e agora
uberlândia o transformaria sete deles
aqui faria muito sentido os gringos
vírus olha o pessoal gosta tanto de obra
aqui no brasil que nós criamos uma
cidade para o verl é certo mas enfim
taxistas vêm à disposição como um risco
motoristas de caminhão vinha de sua
opção como risco e várias pessoas vêem a
sua opção como risco justamente por ser
um risco para tanta gente ela também é
uma baita oportunidade para um monte de
gente mas o que é uma oportunidade certo
o que como se define uma oportunidade e
isso é tão difícil que eu recorri de um
professor nelsinho glenn professor de
banho e falou encontrar um segmento um
problema para o segmento de cliente pelo
qual está com pagar dentro de um mercado
grande o suficiente e você tem que
conseguir resolver isso obviamente isso
é uma oportunidade existe muita
oportunidade com corrupção
a gente viu maiores potencial e
certamente cada vez mais as coisas serão
discutidas a empresa que vocês trabalham
hoje a empresa que nem existe ainda será
afundada vai ser cumprida muito em breve
existem vários exemplos não quero
mostrar pra vocês é por que isso
acontece com tanta intensidade agora e
por que isso acontecia um pouco menos no
passado houve pelo menos demorava mais
pra acontecer é disso que quero falar
com vocês no passado alguém tinha uma
idéia o mundo mudava alguém discorda
disso alguém pegada e criar um filamento
que passava corrente elétrica lá dentro
isso as em dia e o mundo mudava thomas
edson criou a lâmpada e alguém criou
como o escopeta fá lo á a prensa e
depois da imprensa o mundo mudou a gente
começou a ter uma uma dispersão de
livros gigantesca certo então alguém
tinha uma grande ideia e o mundo mudava
3.500 anos antes de cristo e inventou
isso daqui que é esse negócio aqui a
roda certo bom vocês sabem o que é esse
negócio aqui é útil é bacana tem
crescido uso isso aqui vai ser bastante
útil daqui alguns anos depois em 1857
quando o estado de minas gerais se
formou como ele é hoje o queijo minas
mais importante do que a roda é
fundamental para tudo o que vem depois
disso daqui sem queijo minas nós não
teríamos a máquina a vapor mentira mas a
máquina a vapor que impulsionou a
revolução industrial vem logo depois e é
também uma das grandes inovações
o doce de leite para dar errado aqui mas
muito bem a onda como eu falei pra vocês
o computador que não era esse computador
feijão da ibm mas ele ficava bom no
slide então coloquei ali bem estatelado
lá depois do computador a gente inventa
uruguaio é a tal da internet quem não
usa também vale muito a pena é muito
legal você consome horas e horas naquele
treco aquele rapaz ali está acessando
procurando alguma coisa meio esquisita
não faça isso agora muito bem isso tudo
em um monte de outras coisas a gente
inventou em 5 mil anos de história
os intervalos foram diminuindo depois do
queijo minas a gente foi aproximando e
foi diminuindo e etc mas na última
década ou expandir nos últimos 15 nos
últimos 20 anos o que foi inventado
se vocês pegarem a home do celular que
vocês não façam isso agora porque vocês
nunca mais prestaram atenção nem um
pouco até por exemplo entrou na onda do
celular ali acabou a bola nunca mais vai
assistir absolutamente nada porque ela
está focado na copa sc e pegar a roupa
do celular que vocês vocês
vários aplicativos esses aplicativos
quase todos senão todos foram inventados
últimos dez quinze ou vinte anos
o próprio smartphone foi inventado nos
últimos dez anos parece maluco porque
ele faz parte do nosso dia-a-dia de uma
maneira muito intensa mas ele tem menos
de 10 anos mas fones começaram a se
proliferar bastante em 2007 o então
quase completando a atenção uma criança
a pergunta principal é mais empresas
morreram
as empresas vocês lembram que existiam
eram gigantes que faziam parte do nosso
dia a dia e desapareceram por completo
que me dá um exemplo nunca tinha ouvido
exemplo ótimo exemplo muito bom que é
mais um blockbuster quem sabe uma
locadora de vídeo aqui muito bem
quentinha ataque a bola chegou até aqui
em uberlândia
quem tinha carteirinha da blockbuster
aqui quem alugou um filme uma locadora
tem ainda lugar uma locadora tenta
encontrar a netflix opção ok
entendemos como é que funciona o negócio
é assim muitas empresas morreram em
várias vão sumir a esse taxista em
itaqui de táxi modelo da hitachi de 99
já morreram elas têm cinco anos mas
modelo delas morreu
o modelo de táxi modelo moribundo certo
modelo que já funciona é tanto que elas
estão mudando até tirando isso do nome
tirando o tateando o pax do nome e ver o
iso e plus 99 apenas porque eles
entendem que o modelo morreu e se
adaptar é fundamental que isso acontece
lá atrás alguém tinha uma ideia e o
mundo mudar agora ainda é assim
agora as coisas mudaram bastante mudaram
por razões muito simples eu quero
mostrar pra vocês são duas razões
centrais têm outras várias concorrentes
mas duas ações centrais que fazem com
que isso mude pra caramba e depois eu
quero apresentar para vocês como é que a
gente pode se adaptar
nessa realidade de um futuro
completamente imprevisível de uma era
exponencial em que a cada dois dias
isso em 2010 a cada dois dias nós
queremos mais conteúdo do que nós
criaremos no total até 2013 nós tínhamos
um total criado até 2013 e depois a
partir daqui de 2010 a cada dois dias a
gente gera mais e mais conteúdo segundo
o presidente do google só ter uma idéia
da quantidade de conteúdo que gera hoje
em dia todo mundo tem acesso qualquer um
de vocês pode pegar e assistir em tag
qualquer um de vocês pode aprender
o que é um computador hackear um negócio
assistindo um vídeo qualquer um de vocês
têm acesso absolutamente a tudo pela
primeira vez na história todo mundo tem
acesso a qualquer momento você pega o
celular tira do bolso você acesse o
google e você tem todas as informações
do planeta disponíveis na sua mão
isso é uma quebra de paradigma
gigantesca não se enganem porque isso é
gigantesca a gente não percebe no dia a
dia mas pensem a 20 e 30 anos você não
teria esse acesso
outra coisa mudança de mais 7 a nossa
cabeça mudou quando se você já usaram
uma barbie ou qualquer serviço de
compartilhamento para as pessoas já
utilizaram certo hoje
quem já ouviu aquela frase não fale com
estranhos com essa frase da vida em
filme certo já ouviu essa frase quem tem
quem já conversou com quem sobre os
atrasos uma vez hoje nós entramos no
carro do estranho não dormimos na casa
de estranhos sem estar bem - nós já
acionamos na casa de estranhos
nós fizemos várias coisas com os
estranhos simplesmente porque a gente
permite pra gente fazer isso nós uma em
7 mudou por conta de acesso a redes
sociais uma tecnologia pujante que
cresce a cada dia se você acessar o meu
facebook segue de volta à tevê trocou
alex você acessar em vocês vão saber
várias coisas sobre a minha vida vão ter
várias informações sobre mim que há 20
anos você não saberiam absolutamente
nada poderia vir aqui falar falar um
nome diferente do meu embora e ninguém
nunca mais me encontraria agora vocês
conseguem ter acesso a nossa mudança de
mais sete faz com que nesse mundo
exponencial um acesso absoluto as coisas
mudem a maneira de inovar mude
dentro disso é um desafio enorme se
manter vivo e acho que inclusive no
futuro vai ser cada vez mais complicada
por esse negócio pra isso tem algumas
coisas chávez eu quero passar com elas
rapidamente por vocês primeiro estudo
focado desde os básicos quando se vai a
blockbuster outra uma locadora o que
quer
o filme não é o filme você vai à bola
que batera uma locadora o que você quer
é um entretenimento que a gente
aproveite
você não quer alugar o filme ninguém sai
de casa e falar e eu vou pegar pegar um
pedaço de plástico enviar um dvd e vai
ser ótimo vai ser incrível
ninguém quer isso não é nem o filme
quantas vezes já vi aquele pessoal
falando assim a tal vida social começou
a maratona de séries é alguém já deve
ter feito isso aqui provavelmente já
agora acabou a vida social saiu série 9
etc
significa que a série o filme e tudo
aquilo que compete com seu
entretenimento vida social também
então você compete por um raio uma gama
de coisas gigantescas
você vai à ponta de lança você quer
entretenimento
quando você anda de uber você não quer
dar a dilma ninguém gosta de andar de
carro a cessão de um prazer momentâneo
mas no geral no dia-a-dia andar de carro
é uma maneira de você chegar um outro
fim ele é um meio você não deseja mudar
de casa deseja ir do ponto a ao ponto b
isso é igual desde as cavernas eu queria
ir a pé a cavalo carroça zipcar carro
alugado berço inventário teletransporte
rubber morre no dia seguinte certo você
precisa ter isso muito claro se você
focar na dor que você focar no desejo
básico ele é permanente ele muda com
pouca freqüência nós somos iguais desde
sempre
então é muito permanente já a solução
ela muda a todo momento e cada vez mais
rápido é cada vez mais difícil de você
dentro de um grupo dentro de uma empresa
tem que acompanhar isso era vez o
crowdsourcing a alaga mais a nossa vida
com esse monte de coisa não seja o dono
do modelo aquele cara que falam que eu
passo é isso você é o dono do modelo eu
imprimo jornal mas ninguém mas é mais um
primo jornal é isso que eu faço é por
essa empresa foi fundada não foi
surpresa foi fundada para entregar
informação com credibilidade no mundo em
que todo mundo produz conteúdo a única
diferença do conteúdo do jornal é que
ele tem um selo um selo de que diz que
aquilo é verdade ou pelo menos próximo
disso certo você não é o dono do modelo
você imprimir o jornal você entrega a
informação isso é o que tem valor para
as pessoas só isso quem já viu um site
na internet
quem já viu erro lembro do yahoo fazer
aquele barulhinho legal
alguém lembra do carro muito bem o yahoo
é um portal o portal eu falo vocês
escutam certo à internet via 2.0 eu falo
você me responde à internet vira 3.0
você fala com ela e seu não participar
eu tô fora da jogada que acontece com o
yahoo o valor vai despencando
despencando despencando até que ele não
vai mais quase nada é vendido agora
recentemente
já o facebook é uma plataforma que
conecta pessoas vejam a diferença em uma
plataforma que conecta pessoas quando
surge mobile para o facebook vai morrer
ele vai se tornar obsoleto vai vir uma
rede social o bairro vai matar o fez até
será a corrente vigente e que acontece
no facebook exponencial porquê porque
ele conecta pessoas aí faz aquisições
quais são as aquisições whatsapp que é o
10 uma ferramenta que conecta pessoas
por mensagem
ele adquire o instagram que é o
instagram é uma ferramenta que conecta
pessoas por meio de fotos é adquirir um
óculos ruir e o que o óculos rio é uma
ferramenta que conecta
a realidade virtual o facebook compra
ele mesmo a todo momento e por isso ele
não morre porque ele não fica preso a
uma coisa só é mutável é uma solução na
faixa dos competidores a tese a
fabricante de carros elétricos nos
estados unidos querem romper o mercado
de energia no mercado de automóveis ela
vai lá e o maior custo de um carro ao é
60% desse custo do peso de 60 é a
bateria ela gasta uma grana violentas
desenvolvendo poderia em pesquisa e
desenvolvimento e em certo momento ele
consegue a bateria aquela seria a
fórmula secreta da coca cola da tesla o
elo mais doce ou libera as patentes
online para todo mundo as ações caem
despenco falando que ela ficou maluco
esse cara tá voltando a empresa esse
cara não quer nada com nada
a ideia eu espero chegar no próximo
nível das baterias e levaria 15 anos eu
abro os concorrentes levo cinco eu
atingi meu objetivo de descobrir o
mercado de energia muito mais rápido a
previsão agora são três deles romper ice
referências cruzadas eu tive com o
diretor de um hospital
a diretora de uma escola de criatividade
britânica e ele estava me contando sobre
um gerente um diretor da ferrari de pit
stops aqueles negócios top contando que
ele teve um hospital e viu aquele
entendimento do tj tipo naquela série
foi vítima ele gravava as coisas em jogo
é um pouco mais velho do que vocês e vem
frenético ok ele pega lá e aquela cena
aquela coisa tem saída e tetra e aí ele
olhou e falou para a gente troca o pneu
passagem do piloto uma asa ou em
combustível é um misto quente massagem
no pé do cara em três segundos como é
que a gente faz essa bagunça sem falar
uma coisa que faz essa bagunça uma
pessoa e propôs um experimento para que
você melhorar seu atendimento no
hospital e com isso a sem muitos
detalhes os primeiros socorros
melhoraram em 34% o resultado para o
super positivo mas pensa que não tinha
nada a ver com o ambiente trouxe esse
resultado super positivo atacar o status
quo se você quer descobrir não ser
interrompida muito claro você vai atacar
os cursos você vai ficar parado e alguém
vai fazer isso
o erro quem já viu que é bom quem chutou
para uma cadeira o dinho foi bom na
primeira vez foi bom na segunda ou na
terceira errar uma merda sempre
invariavelmente rádio é ruim
estatisticamente é bem provável que você
não é na sua vida certo vai acontecer o
importante é nós
a primeira aprender com erros é
fundamental eu tenho uma cadeira no
interior faz um arco assim
e toda vez de chutar com o pé toda vez
eu estava perto é um dia que está
chegando perto e vi aquele dia eu falei
eu aprendi esse erro de quase quebrado
meu dedo 10 valeu a pena tudo isso ter
de novo mas enfim
outra coisa permitir o erro se você não
permite o erro as pessoas a não votar
mais conforto e se elas não vão longe da
sua zona de conforto elas não inovam e
ninguém diz rompe sem tentar errar você
vai ter que ralar para romper não tem
jeito
destruir o seu próprio modelo em cima do
facebook em cima de todas as mesas na
califórnia no facebook um livrinho na
primeira página basicamente o que ele
diz é o seguinte todos os dias de manhã
a função da principal de todos os
funcionários é tentar destruir parece
observo tentar destruir o que é o fez
certo é o que eles têm que fazer porque
se você não destruir o seu modelo alguém
vai ter muito claro que alguém vai
destruir seu modelo se não for você não
destrua o seu modelo tenha muito claro
que isso é importante para você fazer o
que vem por aí eu quero fazer uma
passagem muito rápida com vocês o táxi
meio claro né
já está empacotando vamos ficar um pouco
mais complicada advogados quem viu
aquele advogado tem um advogado um robô
em nova york que reverte multas reverteu
uma unidade em são paulo morre de medo
de si para chegar lá e esse advogado
para revertê-la 19 mil multas por mesma
coisa do tipo a um motorista de caminhão
como foi falado aqui agora pouco o já
tem um motorista o caminho autónomo
certo mas o caminho autónomo que mata o
motorista de caminhão com profissão ele
substituiu também eu digo que ele dura
cinco anos e com ele o setor de
logística inteiro como ele é hoje deve
morrer
a impressora 3d vai matar esse setor
inteiro vai criar um novo ambiente em
que as coisas chegam até a sua casa tem
você precisa buscar sempre fazer
transportado de uma fazenda por um
supermercado foi levado para sua casa
reduzindo custos reduzindo a dor
reduzindo o atrito nesse processo todo
além do setor de logística para com quem
já fez uma ligação para josé contente a
morrer
a gente só não faz isso porque aí a
gente ainda está preso ele o trabalho ai
combinator que é uma aceleradora de
estar tanto nos estados unidos acaba de
lançar um programa de geral indica que
eles fazem eles dão 10 mil dólares para
77 pessoas fazendo com que elas quiserem
durante dez anos absolutamente que elas
quiserem
elas podem trabalhar mais para estudar
lá podem ficar sem fazer nada elas podem
parcelas podem vir aqui para uberlândia
elas podem
o que elas quiserem elas ficam livres
fazendo porque o desempenho que o
trabalho deve sumir deve assumir porque
a gente vai sendo substituído cada vez
mais portugueses em especial o bom e
certo e aí o que acontece porque esse
trabalho somem a nossa estrutura de
governo a gente deve inovar também
desaparece a nossa estrutura econômica
como ela é hoje ela começa a não fazer
sentido você não toca mais o seu tempo e
suas experiências por alguma pecúnia
para você trocar os serviços e bens que
é basicamente a nossa base da economia e
aí sim só que some a nossa estrutura
social desaparece são provocações que eu
quero fazer para vocês que eu quero
deixar com vocês
existe um futuro que não vemos é muito
importante e eu quero pedir para mostrar
que não quer exigir que vocês saiam
daqui e leva isso para outros lugares
levem para outras pessoas levem para os
ambientes levem essas informações esses
questionamentos você estiver patrão
comigo de pato online passa o que vocês
acharam que é importante que essas
informações a gente mundo super bacana
tudo no mundo exponencial hoje não são
inspirados de várias maneiras
o que eu acho mais importante de tudo é
que vocês levem isso pra frente e foram
selecionados não por acaso tem muita
coisa pra gente fazer aqui pro futuro
então com isso eu quero agradecer muito
a presença de todos vocês é uma coisa
tem duas opções uma onda a onda vai
chegar à praia pode chegar pode surfar o
seu caranguejo que dorme a onda leva a
ijet muito obrigado e um em uma boa
tarde
[Aplausos]